I'm obviously here to talk about Creed 3
but not really anymore so uh like it all
changed so um what is the name of your
dog this is Coltrane and how long how
old is Coltrane he's five uh rescue
rescue
um full rescue yeah um so is this like
are you guys Inseparable yeah we we go a
lot of places together and we just got
back from the Press store and he
couldn't come so that's why I was like
you're coming to work today because I'm
not leaving you she actually he spent
some time on the Creed 3 set so he is
and he has been in a film he but he's
sorely disappointed that I didn't put
him in this one he's like I'm a nepho
baby why which why which film did he get
it he I made a film with Steve Buscemi
which that's how you say it not bushebe
it blew my mind when I learned that a
year ago and he is in the film is he
dreading sitting there is he super happy
no he's super happy he's just relaxed
um yeah I first of all everything about
this is amazing and second of all I I
wish I could have a dog we have cats
because of my schedule do you get if you
can bring them to to like sets and
everything yeah yeah yeah he's he's been
on the Westworld set he's he's been
around he's he's like a seasoned set dog
guy I was gonna say I think you need to
work it in your contract got the dog in
my rider yeah exactly that uh he walks
by in certain in my woofer you know
um yeah and now he's like I don't know
if I want to stay here yeah well he yeah
I mean he he's gorgeous thank you so
much yes okay so now I'll ask you maybe
a question or two oh dear
this breath smells so bad
I love him so much oh so obviously this
is Michael's first time directing a
movie yeah and I'm just curious what
surprised you and he's out yeah once it
wasn't about him he was done
um what actually surprised you about
working with Michael as a director that
um perhaps you weren't expecting
um
I wasn't he cares so much about clothes
he's very meticulous about what
characters are wearing and that hasn't
always been the case often what I work
with male directors they they're like I
don't know just wear a shoe and he's
like no but what kind of shoot that
surprised me what did not surprise me is
how he's such an incredible leader and
such a lovely I mean he really bolsters
the spirit of camaraderie and
collaboration and and he you know he
makes everyone happy when he comes to
set which I knew that he he's always
done that as an actor but when you're
balancing the challenges of being a
director I didn't know if you know if he
could manage to still bring that kind of
energy and attention to everybody that
he did well oftentimes people like to
they talk about making a sequel or a
prequel to whatever it may be this is
the third Creed movie this is a trequel
right exactly I think it's it's a it's a
three equal but anyway what did you
realize what is it like actually being
part of a franchise like this it's not
Marvel and that that resonates with so
many people
you know I think I realized pretty early
in the sense that it was even before I I
had seen the film Creed one but I think
we went to Philadelphia for a press run
and we went to like the iconic stairs
where the Rocky statue is and there were
so many fans there but the thing that
surprised me is they were so
intergenerational you know there were
such there were young fans there were I
mean and such a cross-section of people
um which makes sense because Ryan cooler
himself was such a fan of the rocky
franchise it meant so much to him and
his family and so I guess I I was
initially surprised by what the fan base
looked like and how enduring the the
series had been and so I think that we
were borrowing from that that we were
doing something inside of that world but
also speaking to A Whole New Generation
I think realizing that and that it
potentially you know could mean
something to a lot of people because of
that I think that was the thing that was
really remarkable to realize